- Cette boutique de produits
en vrac ferme ses portes demain.
ANNIE MARTEL, propriétaire,
Terre à soi
- Demain, on a décidé
de fermer, effectivement.
- Pourquoi?
- Pour envoyer un message clair
comme société, que la planète
a besoin plus d'un black-out
que d'un Black Friday.
(chahut)
- Voici à quoi ressemblaient
les Vendredis fous avant
nes.
Mais ut
de contre-culture s'oppose
à cette cultude conde conde con,
c'est l'impact de la
consommation abusive ou de la
consomconsomconsomconsomconsomm.
Le Black Friday, on est bombardé
de publicité, tout le mondeous r
à tout prix.
- L'Observatoire de la
consomponsable
de l'UQAM analyse le phénomème
et constate que, depuis las onts
habitudes de consommation pour
les rendre plus responsables.
FABIEN DURIF, dir. Observ. de la
tion responsable, UQAM
- Le Vendredi fou classique
est en train de s'essouffler.
Le consobais, mais il cherche
aussi un sens à sa consommation.
L'objectif, ce n'est pas de
ne pas consommer
de mieux consommer.
zéro déchet qui nous
permettent de réduire, après,no.
- Une épicerie écologique
zéro déchet qui a décidé, auté.
ANDRÉANNE LAURAIN, directrice
le, Épicerie Loco
- Demain, en fait, on va
remettre 10 % de tous
nos revenus, fait
les revenus pour des organismes
locaux.
- Il s'agit d'un
des adeptes.
- Le fait d'avoir des rabais quu
attrayants, où les prix ont été
gonflés juste pour la journée,a.
- Moi aussi, je trouve que
- Une réflexion quitombe tombe e
de la période de Noël.
st,
dans les Laurenti